ORDER.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF SAID LAST
NIGHT HE WOULD NOT OPT TO WEAR A
MASK.
WITH US NOW THE FORMER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES, JEFF SESSIONS, RUNNING
FOR HIS 0 OLD SENATE SEAT IN
ALABAMA AND KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN
US RIGHT NOW.
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
>> THANK YOU, NEIL.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
NEIL: LET ME ASK YOU HOW YOU
FEEL -- SAME HERE, SIR.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT REQUIRING
VERSUS URGING PEOPLE TO WEAR
MASKS?
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL THOSE IN
ALABAMA ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK WHENEVER POSSIBLE
PEOPLE SHOULD WEAR MASKS.
I WOULD SUPPORT THAT FOR SURE.
IF SOMEBODY’S OUT IN THEIR YARD
AND NOT CLOSE TO ANYONE, I DON’T
THINK THEY HAVE TO WEAR THE
MASK.
AND I GUESS IT’S SOMEWHAT AN
INDIVIDUAL DECISION, BUT THERE
IS NO DOUBT THAT YOU DO EXPEL
DROPLETS AND EVEN THE MOST BASIC
CLOTH MASK CAN HELP MAKE A
PERSON LESS CONTAIN--
CONTAGIOUS AND LESS LIKELY TO
SPREAD THE VIRUS.
NEIL: ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC,
SENATOR, WE COULD GET TO A POINT
-- BY THE END OF THIS MONTH WE
COULD START EASING BACK SOME OF
THE STAY AT HOME AND SHELTER IN
PLACE MEASURES, 41 STATES,
INCLUDING ALABAMA HAVE NOW?
>> I ABSOLUTELY HOPE WE CAN DO
THAT.
IT’S SO IMPORTANT WE DO NOT NEED
TO PROLONG THIS ECONOMIC
CATASTROPHE, REALLY, ANY LONGER
THAN WE HAVE TO.
IF THE $2 TRILLION IS ONE OF
THE--
THE LARGEST EXPENDITURE OF MONEY
IN AMERICAN HISTORY, ALL OF
THAT’S BORROWED SO WE DO NEED TO
SEE AND TAKE EVERY SMART EFFORT
TO BE AS EFFECTIVE,
PRODUCTTIVELY FOR OUR ECONOMY AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN, AND PROLONGED
UNNECESSARY DELAYS ARE REALLY,
HAVE GREAT POTENTIAL FOR HARM.
NEIL: NOW, YOU ARE IN A RUNOFF
WITH THE FORMER FOOTBALL COACH
FOR THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION
FOR THE SENATE.
DO YOU THINK THAT SUMMER RUNOFF
ELECTION SHOULD BE DELAYED?
>> WELL, IT HAS BEEN DELAYED.
IT WAS DELAYED A GOOD BIT NOW TO
JULY 14TH, AND IT IS DTDZ, BUT
THERE ARE WAYS TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THE PEOPLE OF ALABAMA.
YOU CAN’T TRAVEL AND HAVE
RALLIES AND EVENTS LIKE WE’VE
DONE IN THE PAST, BUT SOCIAL
MEDIA, ON THE COMMUNICATION,
CONFERENCE CALLS, TELEVISION,
RADIO TALK SHOWS HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE FOR ME AND HAVE DONE A
LOT OF THAT, SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
WE CAN’T JUST STOP WHAT WE’RE
DOING, WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT
SENATE RACE TO BE DECIDED THIS
SUMMER AS TO WHO WILL
REPRESENT--
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
WANTED TO PUSH THAT BACK,
SENATOR, EVEN BEYOND JULY 14TH.
AS YOU KNOW, DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION ITSELF WAS PUSHED
BACK FROM MID JULY TO MID
AUGUST.
DO YOU THINK IT IS WISE NOW TO
DO WHAT THE NATIONAL PARTY DID,
THE NATIONAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY, I
KNOW IT’S DIFFERENT HERE, THAT
CONFERENCE HAS BEEN PUSHED BACK
AT LEAST TWICE.
>> I THINK WITH REGARD TO
ALABAMA WE REALLY NEED TO GET
THIS ELECTION DONE, I THINK IT’S
ONE OF THE LATEST ELECTIONS YOU
CAN HAVE AND CARRY OUT A
NOVEMBER ELECTION IN A PROPER
WAY.
I THINK THAT’S WHERE WE’RE
HEADING.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE SAYS THAT
PEOPLE CAN VOTE ABSENTEE IF
THEY’RE FEARFUL OF THEIR HEALTH
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
CONDUCT THIS ELECTION AND EXPECT
IT WILL BE CONDUCTED JULY 14TH.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS YOU’VE
ATTACHING YOURSELF CLOSELY TO
THE PRESIDENT, APPARENTLY HIS
CAMPAIGN DEMANDED THAT YOU STOP
IT, AND SAYING THAT, YOU ARE
DILUTIONAL IN DOING SO.
HAVE YOU STOPPED EITHER
REFERENCING IN YOUR MAILINGS OR
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND YOUR ATTACHMENT TO
HIM?
>> WELL, I SAID I WAS SUPPORTING
HIM, THAT I WAS HIS TOP MOST
PROMINENT NATIONAL SUPPORTER,
THE FIRST ONE TO--
IN THE SENATE TO ANNOUNCE THAT
SUPPORT.
I CONTINUE TO SUPPORT HIS
IMMIGRATION POLICIES, HIS TRADE
POLICY.
I SUPPORT HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE
VIRUS, I THINK HE’S DOING A
GREAT JOB AS PRESIDENT AND NO
LAWYER FROM WASHINGTON CAN SAY
THAT I CAN’T SAY I SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT.
I WILL ALSO SAY THAT I DON’T
THINK THERE’S ANYBODY IN ALABAMA
THAT DOESN’T KNOW WE HAD A
DISAGREEMENT.
I DID WHAT I THOUGHT WAS RIGHT
AND I THOUGHT WAS RESPONSIBLE
AND REQUIRED OF ME.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY THIS,
WASHINGTON’S BEEN WRONG BEFORE.
I INTEND TO TAKE MY CASE TO THE
PEOPLE OF ALABAMA UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION, THEY DECIDE WHO
THEIR SENATOR IS.
I BELIEVE I’M BEST QUALIFIED TO
HELP THEM.
I HAVE A RECORD OF ADVANCING
THEIR VALUES, OUR PRINCIPLES
WITH INTEGRITY AND VIGOR AND
THAT’S WHAT I’LL BE DOING WHEN I
TAKE MY CASE TO THE PEOPLE OF
ALABAMA.
NEIL: WELL, AS YOU KNOW, SIR,
THE PRESIDENT IS SUPPORTING
COACH TUPPERVILLE HERE, WERE YOU
MURT WHEN HE ANNOUNCED THAT?
>> LOOK, THE PRESIDENT IS FREE
TO MAKE HIS OWN DECISIONS, WE
HAD A DISAGREEMENT.
I BELIEVE THE PEOPLE OF ALABAMA
UNDERSTAND ME, THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT WE LIKE THE PRESIDENT, I
DO, AND WE WANT HIM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL, WANT HIM TO CONTINUE
TO BE A GREAT, GREAT PRESIDENT.
I’LL BE A BIG SUPPORTER OF HIS
AND WE’VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT BIG
ISSUES LIKE CHINA AND HOW THIS
HAPPENED, AND NEIL.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR AMERICA,
PARTICULARLY WHAT I LEARNED AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES, THAT WE NEED TO STAND UP
NOW TO IDENTIFY AND POINT OUT
CHINA’S FAILURE TO TELL THE
WORLD ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC.
ONE STUDY IN ENGLAND SAID 95% OF
THE INFECTIONS WOULD NOT HAVE
OCCURRED HAD THIS BEEN REPORTED
THREE WEEKS EARLIER.
SO THIS IS A COLOSSAL DISASTROUS
FAILURE AND WE NEED TO KNOW AS
WE DEAL WITH CHINA IN ALL KINDS
OF AREAS THAT THEY DON’T TELL
THE TRUTH, THEY’RE SEEKING
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE, UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE, AND IF WE DO THE
RIGHT THING, WE BET ON AMERICA,
WE STAND UP TO THIS, AND I HAVE
A PLAN FOR IT.
FIRST, WE NEED AN INVESTIGATION,
WE NEED TO INVESTIGATE HOW THEY
HAVE COVERED THIS UP AND THE
EXTENT OF THE DAMAGE.
WE NEED TO IDENTIFY MEDICINES
AND HOW WE’VE BECOME DEPENDENT
ON CHINA FOR THAT AND STOP IT.
WE’VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT--
>> WAIT A MINUTE, SENATOR, ARE
YOU SAYING THAT THE CHINESE--
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE CHINESE
LIED?
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
GONE THAT FAR.
HE’S CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHINA
VIRUS, HOW IT STARTED THERE,
HE’S NOT TAKEN THE STEP THAT YOU
HAVE, THAT THE CHINESE WERE
DELIBERATELY MISLEADING ON THE
EARLY NUMBERS, YOU HAVE.
>> I THINK HE SAID REPEATEDLY
HE’S NOT HAPPY WITH WHAT HE WAS
TOLD FROM CHINA.
HE’S TRIED TO MAINTAIN A
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LEADER OF CHINA WHICH I
CERTAINLY THINK IS APPROPRIATE,
BUT WHAT WE AS A NATION NEED TO
DO IS HELP THE PRESIDENT BE MORE
EFFECTIVE.
HE’S BEEN THE FIRST ONE TO
CHALLENGE CHINA.
HE’S HAD IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS TO CHINA,
HE’S USED TARIFFS, HE NEEDS TO
BE SUPPORTED IN THAT AND
CONTINUE THIS THROUGH A PERIOD
OF YEARS AND STAND UP TO THE
ABUSES.
NEIL: SENATOR, IF YOU’RE RIGHT
ABOUT THIS, IF YOU’RE RIGHT
ABOUT THIS AND MANY AGREE WITH
YOU, SIR, THAT THE CHINESE DID
KIND OF SNOOKER US ON THIS AND
MAYBE THEY SNOOKERED US ON TRADE
OR TRUST TO AGREE TO ANYTHING IS
MISPLACED.
DO YOU FEEL THE CHINESE ARE
SAYING ABOUT THIS NOW PANDEMIC
OR EVEN COMMITMENT AND PROMISES
THEY’VE MADE ON TRADE SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT CAUTIOUSLY?
>> YES.
IT’S TIME FOR US TO RESET OUR
RELATIONSHIP.
WE CAN HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH CHINA IN THE YEARS TO COME,
BUT IT CANNOT BE FOUNDED UPON
LIES AND DECEIT AND UNFAIR TRADE
AGREEMENTS WITH ACTIONS BY
CHINA.
WE’VE GOT TO STAND UP TO THEM.
IF THEY DON’T LET US SELL IN
THEIR MARKETS, WE NEED TO REDUCE
THEIR ABILITY TO SELL IN OUR
MARKETS.
IF THEY STEAL OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY, WE NEED TO PROSECUTE
THEM.
WE’VE GONE FROM ZERO
PROSECUTIONS OF CHINESE ENTITIES
TO AFTER MY TIME AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THEY ARE THERE ARE NOW
50 CASES WITH OVER A THOUSAND
INVESTIGATIONS ONGOING ABOUT
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY FROM CHINA.
WE’VE GOT TO END THIS AND GET ON
A HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP.
IT WILL BE THE BEST THING FOR
OUR PEACE AND PROSPERITY IN THE
FUTURE ABOUT WHAT--
THE IDEA THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE--
AND LET THEM WIGGLE OFF THE HOOK
AND DENY THAT THEY SUPPRESSED
THESE DOCTORS, SUPPRESS
REVEALING TO THE WORLD OF THE
DANGERS OF THIS PAM PANDEMIC AS
IT WAS SPREADING, IT’S ONE OF
THE GREATEST COVERUPS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
IT IS A COLOSSAL DISASTER AND
THEY HAVE GOT TO BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT.
THE WORLD NEEDS TO KNOW IT.
THEY DON’T NEED TO GET THE
DENYING, DENYING, DENYING AS
THEY’VE DONE IN THE PAST.
WE NEED TO HOLD THEM TO ACCOUNT
AND ESTABLISH IT.
IT WILL BE GOOD FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CHINA TO SEE THAT THE
LEADERSHIP, THE COMMUNIST PARTY
DID NOT GET AWAY WITH IT.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, FINALLY, SIR, I
KNOW YOU’VE BEEN ASKED THIS
MANY, MANY TIME IN THIS NOW
FRACTIOUS RELATIONSHIP YOU HAVE
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
TO THIS DAY, HE BLAMES YOUR
RECUSAL FOR THE UNWINDING OF
THIS INVESTIGATION THAT HE
CALLED A WITCH HUNT, BUT THAT HE
CLAIMS IT ALL STARTED WITH YOU
AND HE HAS NEVER FORGOTTEN OR
CLEARLY FORGIVEN YOU FOR THAT.
DO YOU THINK HE EVER WILL?
>> WELL, WE HAD A DISAGREEMENT
OVER MY DECISION THAT I FELT I
WAS OBLIGATED TO DO TO RECUSE
MYSELF.
OTHERWISE, WE’VE HAD A
HARMONIOUS PARTNERSHIP ON THE
GREAT ISSUES OF OUR TIME AND I
WOULD INTEND TO CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE THAT HARMONIOUS
RELATIONSHIP
RELATIONSHIP.
NEIL: WOULD YOU HAVE ANY REGRETS
NOW?
YOU HAD TO DO IT ALL OVER AGAIN,
WOULD YOU?
>> YOU NEVER REGRET DOING WHAT
YOU BELIEVE IS THE RIGHT THING,
NEIL.
I WAS CONVINCED I HAD TO DO
THAT.
I WAS REQUIRED TO DO THAT ON MY
FAITH AND MY COMMITMENT TO LAW
IS SUCH THAT I WOULD NEVER FAIL
TO DO MY DAUGHTER UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I DID WHAT I FELT I HAD TO DO.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR, VERY GOOD, WE’LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE VIRUS AND
THE CHINA THING YOU’RE TAKING TO